hello everyone coming to you all like
Cara said from beautiful Los Angeles
California I think we can all agree it
has been an absolutely fantastic morning
and now we have a time and an
opportunity for a really special keynote
guest we have the opportunity to hear
from Optimist and Global best-selling
author Simon synic Simon has devoted his
life to advance a vision in which the
vast majority of people wake up feeling
inspired safe and fulfilled by the work
that they do Simon is known for
best-selling books including start with
why Leaders Eat Last and the infinite
game you may have heard his podcast a
bit of optimism or seen his Ted Talk on
the concept of why which has over 60
million views wow Simon thank you so
much for being with us today we are
super excited to have you thanks for
having me yes All Right audience to
everyone out there I have a few
questions pre-planned for Simon to get
us kicked off and started in this
fireside chat but if you'd like we'd
love for you to jump in to our chat
function and I'll ask Simon those
questions that you guys have all right
Simon you ready ready all right 60
million views on your Ted Talk is super
impressive so tell us the the why behind
how you started this philosophy what
your journey was and what brought you to
the concept of why it's a very personal
story and quite frankly it started out
of pain I lost my passion for my work um
but superficially things were good so I
was actually quite embarrassed about
saying to people oh I don't want to go
to work anymore because everything
looked fine and so I kept those feelings
to myself and if anybody has ever been
in a bad place you know if you keep
those feelings to yourself they grow um
and that's what happened to me and it
wasn't until a dear friend of mine came
to me and said something's wrong
something's off and having that safe
container that safe space I came I came
clean um it lifted a huge weight off my
shoulders and all that energy that I
went to that went into lying hiding and
faking um could go into finding a
solution the solution that I found was
this thing called the why I knew what I
did I knew how I did it but I didn't
know why I was doing what I was doing
and the ability to articulate my why not
only restored my passion to new levels
but the ability to help other people
find their why gave me a A Renewed sense
of purpose and so that's what I sort of
set my life and career to do it's
absolutely amazing and special so thank
you for sharing that piece we look
forward to digging in a little bit more
with it as well um and you mentioned
this just a minute ago and that was
around passion and you've been quoted as
saying working hard for something we do
not care about is called stress but yet
working hard for something we love is
called passion uh so what are the some
of the maybe key principles that someone
can apply to their life to make that
transition from stress to Passion I
think we misunderstand what passion is
we think of it as an input you know it's
like we only hire passionate people well
how do you know that they're passionate
for interviewing not so passionate for
working you know passion is an output
not an input it's something we feel when
we are working in something we love and
care about passion is what we feel when
we work with people who we care for and
care about us um it's got nothing to do
with how many hours we work or how hard
we work or the stress we feel it's to do
with whether all of that feels worth it
if I feel fulfilled by all of that so
passion is definitely an output which is
why it's so important to understand our
why it's why it's so important to uh uh
contribute to the culture that we're
working in because we want to give to
the people we work with uh not just take
from them we want to work in in
cooperation with the people all of that
contributes to that magical feeling of
passion absolutely and it it gives that
Community feel and peace to it as well
ex thank you well we'll take it to Simon
the some of the chat functions uh and
the questions that they that the team
has um and the first one comes in from
Angela uh Montello and that is Simon
what is the biggest challenge facing the
business world today and do you have any
advice in overcoming it I think the
biggest challenge we have today it's
it's there sort of twofold one is I mean
Co definitely took us away from uh
working together and if camaraderie and
community and all of these things matter
so much to human beings it's becoming
really really difficult for us to find
that Community um I think a lot of
companies don't realize that working
remotely and building community and
Trust actually requires more work not
less work it's not just like you know
think of it like school you can't just
have a 50-minute class and repeat you
know all the time uh uh uh and expect
kids to learn as easily you've got to
change the way it works um it's the same
it's the same thing here um so and and
we think about Community do people have
the skills do they have the human skills
to build that Community to build those
relationships um things like active
listening things like how to have an
effective confrontation things like um
uh uh how to give and receive feedback
these are absolutely necessary skills
that we aren't learning so I think
companies have a huge opportunity to
teach people those skills absolutely
that's super exciting to to hear and yes
yes agree so um we have one from Dustin
harms and that is what fulfills
you so I mean I'm going to sound like a
broken record that's okay but uh the
things there's there's a couple things
one is I I love working in teams I love
working with people and the feeling of
accomplishing something with somebody is
for me the best so so relationship
really matters um uh and the other thing
is I'm a sucker for people who serve
those who serve others I can be brought
to tears when I hear stories of somebody
who sacrificed themselves their
interests for the good of others so so
you know Meeting those people who who
give and serve in in work or in in in
life um I I I love that that really
feeds me oh good thank you for sharing
that absolutely another question I in
from Samuel tenbrink and that is how do
you deal with negative thoughts uh you
allow them to happen I think we sort of
we sort of we think we have to be
positive all the time we don't I mean
human beings are feelings I mean human
beings have feelings you know I guess
that's good like we are feelings human
beings have feelings and we can't deny
those feelings if you're sad be sad
allow yourself to be sad if you're if
you're angry allow your to be angry but
just label it I'm sad I'm angry and I
think where it becomes dangerous is when
we try and suppress it and pretend that
we don't have those things because we
have to be happy all those all the time
but allow allow allow yourself to be
human I think is the most important
thing in and just be honest with
yourself about how you feel yeah and is
it does that then enable you to kind of
move past it a little bit of faster or
process it as you kind of acknowledge it
the simple answer is yes um um sort of
going back to my own story The more one
tries to suppress negativity the more it
feeds on itself it's like a valve when
you let it out it releases the pressure
um most importantly uh to let it out to
another human being um you know I think
we live in this world where you know
people stand by themselves too many
people stand by themselves in their
rooms with their phones and make a video
for Tik Tok and say how they're feeling
but you're in a room by yourself talking
to a piece of technology you know you're
not actually talking to a person um but
to have that exact same conversation
with another human being where you're
looking them in the eye is actually much
more difficult even if you were to say
the exact same words um and I think
there there's awesome power in being
able to share how you honestly feel with
others and that others have the skill
set to hold that space not trying and
fix anything and I think that's the
mistake we make when our friends come to
us we try and fix um don't fix just hold
space um and uh yeah that's that's
that's a magical thing if if when you do
it takes courage takes courage but it's
a magical thing
absolutely it um it's special yes so
another question Simon from Shelly
bunner how do you keep a conversation
positive when those around you are
negative um so it happens a lot um and I
sometimes I I point it out I'm like what
what's what's making you so negative I
never say why so negative because it's
ironically the question why is actually
it's an emotional question it's it can
be perceived as aggressive I'm like
what's making so negative like there's a
lot of good things happening here I want
to know more so replacing C judgment
with curiosity is is one part um uh the
other thing is to just allow them to
feel that way so it's like oh yeah I
hear you acknowledging the negativity
and then sort of moving on um but but I
also find that being focused on where
the future is um is important and by the
way not all negativity is bad you know
uh you know people who you know are
sometimes very often criticized at work
because they're always pointing out the
problems and you you hear bosses say say
don't bring me problems bring me
Solutions like Well if I knew the
solution I wouldn't be coming to you you
know um uh I mean there's two there's
two types of negative Nellies you know
there's one that is always negative and
offers no solution and stands on the
sidelines we have I don't need those
people in in in in an organization but
the people who constantly bring problems
but they're willing to roll up their
sleeves and try and find a solution
those people are are extremely valuable
inside an organization because they're
helping us see things cover our blind
spots that we're not seeing um and
they're willing to roll up their sleeves
so not all negativity is bad it's what
we do with that negativity afterwards
we're willing to work together or
willing to just sort of lean back and
and lean out absolutely well it also
kind of reminds me too around um you
know you said the word why right so not
pressing into that it's a it might be
not the right one to say so how do you
then ensure that you're kind of teeing
it up correctly because if it's not all
negative and holding that space are
there any other kind of um tips to
ensure that you can call it out be blunt
but yet uh process it well together I
mean again it is it is um uh it's it's
not about judgment it's about allowing
somebody to be negative but at the same
time we want to redirect right right and
and I'll like I said I'll say it I'll
say I I I don't know what's making you
negative tell me more we in our in our
company have a rule which is if the
reaction is above a five it's about
something else you know it's like why
did you leave the fridge open it's like
hm clearly not about the fridge right
right um you always leave the fridge
open okay do not react about the fridge
sure sure absolutely so it's the same
thing we find that in work like people
sometimes get very amped up about
something and you sort of pay attention
like that reaction to what we're talking
about don't match this is about
something else and this is where good
leadership and good human skills come
into play which is are you able to read
the room and figure out what's going on
here are they having a bad day is there
something else or is there something
that I don't know about the work that
we're doing that I can easily help
address and fix or did somebody just
hangry retired and that's okay too
absolutely well I love the question of
tell me more um because it opens the
door to just that tell me more go on
what else those those are three magical
things to say those are great great
questions to have in your back pocket
absolutely okay Simon so another one
coming in from Megan Longhurst and Megan
says how do you not let other people's
negative energy or negative kind of
context affect you that's their story
and I I say that that it's their story
um I have my life I have doing my things
and um um but I I I I don't let other
people's negativity affects me because
it's it's their life it's their story I
don't know what's going on sure now if
it's a close relationship clearly and
someone's in your space or you have a
close working relationship with somebody
and somebody's in your space and clearly
they're negative but you can address
that again this goes back to those human
skills I I love how we keep coming here
which is so many of us companies so
rarely teach us the human skills of how
to have difficult ult conversations so
if somebody's constantly negative and it
is actually bringing you or the team
down how do you address that without
making it overly aggressive how do you
address that in a way that they will
hear you and so the ability to say I
need to have a difficult conversation
with you on th in Thursday's meeting you
were so negative it brought the team's
energy down and I'm I fear that if you
continue to bring that negative energy
to all of our meetings that it's going
to demoralize the team and then learn to
be quiet and allow somebody to soak that
in like that
that interaction we don't teach that and
so usually it comes out wrong and
usually it escalates or usually we avoid
it we get passive aggressive at work as
well and so things never get addressed
um uh but I think learning the skills of
of difficult human interaction by the
way human interaction is very often
difficult um uh is is a massive
opportunity for for Corporate America
today absolutely and I love how you say
I feel that if we um and it really kind
of um maybe de de escalates things a
little bit and allows for that open
conversation and if somebody gets
defensive like I didn't do that I'm like
I didn't say you did I'm telling you how
I feel absolutely it's this my feelings
are valid you know yes yes they are so
another question from Christina Testa
and that is what's the most
inspirational experience you've ever had
oh my goodness I I I don't know if I've
had the most inspirational experience um
uh for me again it's it's seeing other
people light up you know I get inspired
when um I hear stories of people who
maybe used my work to uh start a
business or profoundly turn their lives
around um um I I you know where people
take risk and are willing to work
together to do difficult things those
those stories inspire me in terms of my
own personal experience I I do a lot of
work with the military and the
opportunity to spend time with people
who have devoted their lives to service
um I I get very very inspired when I
when I spend time with
them oh fascinating absolutely thank you
another one in from uh Alexandria turis
what are your top three tips for
leadership so these these questions come
up a lot you know and you so those
articles written about that like what
are the three most important
characteristics of a leader you know
Vision Charisma you know and I've met
some wonderful fantastic leaders who are
not big Steve Jobs Visionaries you know
and I've met some amazing leaders who
don't seem to have sort of that bounce
off-the-wall Charisma you know they're
sort of The Quiet One sitting in the
corner um I am comfortable saying
however that great leaders the best
leaders I've ever met they will have
courage um leadership is extremely
difficult um sometimes um it's thankless
it's lonely um when things go right you
have to give away the credit when things
go wrong you have to take all the
responsibility well that sucks um uh and
it's sometimes the the gains are
sometimes not immediate um and it takes
tremendous amount of Courage uh to lead
um what's more you know we talk about
integrity I think Integrity takes
courage you know to speak truth to power
to do the right thing in the face of
overwhelming pressure to do the opposite
um all of these things take courage
which I think begs the question then
where does courage come from um uh I
don't believe that courage is an
internal fortitude where you dig down
deep and find the courage I think
courage is external um it's like you
know a world famous trapeze artist has
the courage to try a brand new death
defying act for the first time with a
net they wouldn't try it without the net
it's the net that gave them the courage
and I think so too is it for human
beings that the quality of our
relationships um give us courage you
talk to folks in uniform who do heroic
things they'll never say it was for God
or country it was for the person to the
left or the person to the right it was
the quality of the relationships and so
for us to build courage what we have to
do is invest in relationships because
when you're facing a very difficult
situation
an ethal challenge a work challenge
whatever it is all we need is one person
in our Lives who says I've got your back
I believe in you you have to do this
it's the right thing to do and if
everything goes sideways don't worry
I'll be there with you I mean even just
talking about it you feel like you have
Renewed Energy and so if you have one
person in your life who can provide that
for you at work or at home um you'll be
amazed the amount of Courage you have to
do the right thing and to lead oh I love
hearing all of that and yes you can kind
of feel it is you just listen to um to
you say it uh fizer has four core values
and one of them happens to be courage
and so a a great uh encouragement for uh
our core value and courage another
question coming in from uh David
Rodriguez and that is what uh what steps
do you take to make yourself better so I
love the idea of learning and so to
first of all to make yourself better you
have to recognize that you're not an
expert in anything I'm an expert in
nothing I'm a student in the things that
I that I that I do and you know I may be
a more advanced student than some people
but there's always more to learn so
number one is I I I never think of any
ceiling um I always think of the
opportunity for constant learning and
two um I like being the idiot in the
room like I like spending time with
people who are smarter than me and don't
feel the need to compete against them or
prove that I know as much or more than
they do um in fact I'm very open about
it and the and it kind of goes when we
talked about our feelings you know you
sort of say you know sort of I'm sad I'm
angry the ability to put that out there
the ability to put out in the room um
you guys know more than I do or I'm the
idiot here it actually provides relief
to you forget about them it provide
provides relief to you that you can be
the idiot in the room and you can soak
in new information um so it's one of my
favorite things to say to people which
is you know you know more about this
than I do um uh because it's a relief
for me it let it lets me off the hook
that I've got nothing to prove so it's
it's a lot of it is mindset the mindset
of learning oh that's wonderful yes
thank you so Simon a question from
Carlos Flores who is your inspirational
Mentor so I have a couple um there's a
guy by the name of Bob Chapman who I
wrote about in my book Leaders Eat Last
I met Bob um and I visited his factories
uh and was profoundly moved by what he's
building at his company Barry way Miller
and just by dumb luck um I've become
friends with Bob and he's become an
incredible Mentor for me um uh
become an incredible Mentor for me um uh
and the other the other one is a guy by
the name of Ron brudder um who has he
just has believed in me since the
beginning and this is what I've learned
about mentors you know sort of you know
you a lot of companies have Mentor
programs which I think is funny I don't
think you can assign someone to be a
mentor um uh I I think for me a
definition of a mentor is someone who
always has time for you you know and so
these people who are way more
accomplished than I am or I was at the
time especially um you know I would call
them up and they had time for me I don't
know they saw something in me maybe they
saw themselves in me I don't know and
not everybody has time for us those
people AR won't be your mentors um uh
and and a great mentor relationship both
parties are actually uh learning you
know cuz uh mentors you'll find learn
from the experience as well so it's not
like this wise old person sitting on
high giving dispensing advice but rather
they come with a sense of curiosity as
well which is why they always have time
for you
oh that's wonderful and special and a
great reminder um when it kind of goes
both ways uh in a mentorship capacity so
thank you yeah a question in from
Michael Martin what do you do to refresh
yourself um it's not that different than
other
people um taking breaks okay I mean I
believe you know there's this great
story of two Lumberjacks and every
morning they start chopping wood at the
same time and every day they stop
chopping wood at the same time and every
day one of The Lumberjacks disappears
for about an hour in the middle of the
day and every day he chops more wood
than the other Lumberjack this goes on
for months then finally the one who
works all day stops and says I have to
ask you every day we start at the same
time every day we stop at the same time
every day you disappear for an hour in
the middle of the day every day I work
more hours than you and every day you
chop more wood than me where do you go
for that hour yeah and the other
Lumberjack looks up and says oh I go
home and sharpen my ax um and so I'm a
great believer in taking breaks I'm a
great believer in turning off and most
of us don't know how to take vacation we
t a commute from a beach that's not
taking a vacation that's bringing work
with you to your family's vacation um so
I'm a great believer that when you have
a weekend or a week off um turn off um
obviously there's there's work to do
sometimes and sometimes it's it's
imperfect that's okay but where we we
literally have never taken a vacation I
think that's unhealthy so even if it's
just a day off you know taking Friday
off you know I think that's a good thing
the critical Fe absolutely and is there
any way that you're able to disconnect
do you leave the phone behind do you
what are your kind of tips when you're
on vacation to truly check out um I
don't take my computer with me okay and
I don't like answering emails on a phone
I find it annoying um so I don't take a
computer computer with me so I don't
even have the Temptation um and I tell
everybody um you know uh uh if there's
an emergency while I'm gone figure it
out M you know um and what you what you
find is that it's incredibly empowering
for a leaders for a leader to say to
their team you got this you know there
are very very very few problems that
will come up that require me and only me
to to to input um and it's very
empowering for a team to know that
they're to know that they're responsible
while the bus is away absolutely freeing
for you and empowering for them so a
win-win it's a win-win yes I love it all
right goes back to courage right you got
to have
like all right okay I'm not going to be
involved in this yeah both ways both
ways yeah absolutely all right Simon so
from Kristen Davis uh what books or
podcasts do you utilize to help grow you
as a person and as a leader so um I've
been pretty open about this I actually
struggle to read um I have ADHD and so
paying attention to books has actually
been very difficult everybody thinks I'm
like this big reader that reads hundreds
of books a year I don't um I've written
more books I've read um uh uh but I do
like learning and so the way I learn is
from listening so conversations with
people who are smarter than me being
being that student um always having a
student mindset I mean s will be curious
about what makes other people tick um so
uh insatiable curiosity in conversations
but I like documentaries as well um and
so two documentaries that I would
recommend which are fantastic for sort
of leadership education um one of them
is Senna Senna which is about race card
driver a s even if you're not into
Formula 1 racing it's still a brilliant
documentary and it's still very
enjoyable but basically it highlights
these two archetypes Senna who drives
for passion and Alan Prost who drives
for the numbers you know and if you
compare that to our modern day you know
who's driven by the end ofe goal the
quarterly goal at you know at any cost
versus who's the person who does it for
the love and you start to see how they
command Senate commands tremendous love
and loyalty from the other driver who
are competing against him but they
support him where nobody likes Prost and
you just you start to see these two
archetypes and it ask you know it's
asked the simple question who do you
want to be what kind of Life do you want
to live um do you want to live one of
passion or one obsessed with numbers um
and it's just it puts it out there the
other one is kumare k u m a r e uh it's
it wasn't supposed to be a leadership
documentary but it ends up being a great
leadership documentary of a a
documentarian who sets out to sort of
mock the sort of Guru culture I won't
give anything away no spoilers here but
let's just say something goes wrong okay
and uh and it's actually quite
interesting fascinating and in the uh
race car when you talked about kind of
the passion and then versus the numbers
do you see your kind of concept of
stress versus Passion Play out in that
as well and those kind of principles as
well without a doubt I mean the the the
joy that comes um from doing something
uh for the love of it and ultimately the
I mean s is still High performing race
carder he still wins a lot of races you
know when you do something with joy you
do you do you are a high performer um uh
and when you're only doing it for the
number you're only doing it for the
result you know there's some unethical
behaviors that start to creep in this is
what press was accused of which is
running other drivers off the road
because he needed the points and so you
start to sort of look at our own work
the people who are only obsessed with
numbers you know it creates some
unethical fuzziness sometimes sure and
so I think I think when you do something
for Joy um uh it's amazing how how we
become better performers but also better
performers like more more honest
performers oh that's great
absolutely all right Simon Angela gaffy
h asks um a question around would you
rather ask for permission or just ask
for forgiveness
afterwards I mean that's an easy
one no
braer yeah I've said sorry a lot um uh
I I I've recognized and learned that um
if I ask to do something that's new or
unconventional I'll get a lot of
resistance not because they don't agree
it's because they they're afraid of the
result and um if I'm willing even if I'm
willing to take all the accountability
um I'll give you one silly example you
know I published a book called together
is better which looks like a children's
book but it's for adults and I did some
very new and different things in that
book that the publisher was very
reticent to do um um and um but I sort
of went forwards anyway and and and and
it ended up being this magical little
book that no one ever thought it would
be and because they all ignored it um
the funny thing is it debuted on the New
York Times best seller list and nobody
knew because no one was paying any
attention to the silly little book um
but uh but yeah I I I I don't mind
helping clean up the mess that I make
but I I definitely want to drive
forwards and try new things I love being
I love experimenting and I also know I
think you have to people who like to
experiment you have to recognize that
things don't always go well and when you
experiment you have to take
accountability and when you experiment
things do fail that's the whole point of
experimentation because when if you want
everything to go right that's when you
play it safe so yeah I I I'm totally
fine asking for
forgiveness great and a and a New York
Times bestseller Simon does not sound
like a silly little book oh it is a
magical little it's a magic that's
wonderful very proud of that book and I
I wrote it specifically to be given away
you know the opening on the first page
it says two colon from colon so it's
literally a book that you give to people
you want to inspire or to thank people
for inspiring you oh how special that's
a gift absolutely literally it is all
right Simon so Nicole dorsy asks what
was the last straw that made you think
to yourself I have to make a change and
figure out my why and get out of my
current situation so I mean I went back
to the that experience I had many years
ago where it was it was darkness that
made me realize I had to make a
and I think that's very common for
people who are Ines you realize if you
know I'm at a fork in the road I either
have to affect change or I don't know
how this plays out but it's not good you
know and I think a lot of people have
faced that fork um and again I was very
lucky I had a friend there to hold space
for me which gave me courage goes back
goes back again to Friendship um but uh
um but if we sort of take it to
something more more recent um you know
for example I didn't write anything
during Co and everybody's like oh did
you use the time during Co to write a
book answer is no that's I I can't write
that way I need human interaction and so
it was it was a creative you know sort
of cemetery for me there was no big
Ideas um nothing worth writing about
anyway um uh and um I don't believe in
writer's block I believe that you're in
the wrong environment for creativity to
happen and so I think a lot of people
when they run out of ideas or they get
stuck they blame themselves I don't I
blame my environment um and so that's
easy to change cuz it can't change me
but I can change my environment um and
so for example this year I wasn't having
any ideas and I tried different things
and it wasn't working and so I did I
took a risk and I moved to another
country for 11 weeks I moved to the UK
for 11 weeks for no other reason than to
shake things up and see what happens and
the ideas bubbled it's absolutely
wonderful so I'm a great believer in
changing your routine doing something
different putting your desk in a
different in a different way you know
start inviting a friend over I I've done
this one as well a friend who has is in
a completely different line of business
who has nothing to do what I do CU well
so many of us are working from home by
ourselves find another friend who works
from home by themselves who might be in
a completely different company work
together and simply sit in a room
together it's amazing what happens the
ideas that flow and just having a work
Buddy things like that experiment with
entirely new different ways of working
not all of them will work and you find
the one that works for you and when that
stops working you try something new
again absolutely I love that piece and
it sounds like it can be a small change
a small TW to to a big change to to move
to the UK to move to the UK for for a
few weeks yeah
absolutely um what uh do you this is
from Amy haaku and that is what's your
greatest
fear um I guess it sounds silly but I
think my greatest fear is that my luck
will run
out you know I I'm I I'm I'm happy go
lucky um and uh uh you know people say
you make your own luck I mean I don't I
don't know if that's
true I mean I've been very I you know my
my work has has has gone on longer than
I expected it had it has you know um
than I expected it would rather um you
know when I wrote start with why I
thought okay I'll probably get three
years out of this maybe five at the most
and then it'll be over and it just keeps
going so I'm I'm very grateful for that
absolutely well um we are
too uh so Simon we've got another
question uh from Marie latisa and that
is uh you spoke about your mentors
previously how do you express gratitude
towards those that have poured into you
oh literally I call them up and say
thank you I mean that's exactly what I
do yeah um I'm I make a point of of
saying thank you to people um when they
least expect it I like the telephone you
know picking up and calling picking up
the phone and calling someone saying hey
I I don't think I've told you this in a
while but I'm really really grateful for
what you've given me you know some of
them are good at receiving compliments
and and attitude and some of them aren't
and they deflect but but no I I'm a
great believer that you know send a card
to someone you know just say you and and
and I think we're all guilty of this
which is we don't call people sometimes
who we miss or we love because you're
like oh I want to you know I want to
talk to them for a sizable period of
time and I'm either too tired or the
time zones don't work out and you know I
couldn't find an hour and I've made that
mistake but sometimes calling someone up
and saying I only have five
minutes you know I'm running to a
meeting but I just wanted to say thank
you to you my mind and I just want to
say thank you it it does it goes a long
way it's such a great tip for Life
absolutely agre I've made that same
mistake before and so thank you for that
encouragement one more one more question
Simon and that is um
if you
um if you had to say kind of like what
you most admire in an amazing leader
what are those
characteristics what would that be so we
talked about courage um but somebody who
stays true to Vision I find very
impressive you know I meet a lot of
people who talk about vision and cause
um but at when they face the slightest
pressure they Veer or they FL face a
difficulty they change strategies I have
a lot of respect for people who who are
very very cause-driven um um I mean a
lot of the leaders that we celebrate
with you like their personalities or not
you know your Steve Jobs's and Elon
musk's and you know Richard Branson's I
mean they're very fixated on where
they're going this idealized sense of
the future and they're they're going to
stay on that they're going to stay on
that path um we can debate whether there
are better ways that they could do it or
you know the cultures they create around
them but I have a lot of respect for
people who who have vision and stick to
it it takes a lot of grit absolutely a
lot of grit is right so Simon you
balanced your time really well and and
Mickey Boyce has noticed that as well
and has asked you how do you do that how
do you balance your time so well uh
Believe It or Not uh I use my schedule I
mean I'm a slave to my schedule like so
many other people and I open my schedule
and I go okay that's my
week yes um and so I literally build the
balance in um um I will block off an
entire Friday for example and though I
will work on Fridays no one is allowed
to schedule anything on a Friday so I
I've no prescheduled anything on a
Friday um and that allows me to have
creative time but it allows me to build
in that balance and um um I've been
doing that for years and it wasn't
necessarily a whole Friday some it was a
few hours so between these hours and
these hours you know this hour and this
hour I wouldn't schedule anything and I
was protective of it um so for example
and and like we think of things like
working out you know we we we think of
these things as flexible or we put in
Creative time we think of it is flexible
and somebody says oh can I see you at
3:00 and you look in your calendar and
you know 3:00 was your workout or 3:00
was your your creative time and you go
yeah I can do three and I say oh sorry I
have something else at three what you
know do you have any other options I I'm
very protective now it's not ideal
sometimes if it's very important of
course I I can make the shift um but I'm
I'm really protective of those of those
blocks that I block out for working out
or for for Creative time they're just
they're not available they don't have to
know why I can't see them you know I
don't think anybody wants to know I
can't meet with you because I'm working
out but sometimes that's what it is um
I'm just really protective of those
times well that's an important piece to
be that protective of of you and your
time so outstanding balance and even if
it's just an hour a week hey you got to
start somewhere
right well Simon thank you so much for
your time it has been an absolute joy
and privilege and um we've I know I've
loved it I know the audience back at
home has as well so thank you so much we
greatly appreciate you and the important
value of your time
um thank you my pleasure thank you for
having me I really enjoyed it thank you
very much thank you thank you